>> MANY OF US ARE FRUSTRATED
WITH THE NEARLY 80 MILLION
AMERICANS WHO ARE STILL NOT
VACCINATED, EVEN THOUGH THE
VACCINE IS SAFE, EFFECTIVE AND
FREE.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT FREEDOM OR
PERSONAL CHOICE.
IT’S ABOUT PROTECTING YOURSELF
AND THOSE AROUND YOU.
THE PEOPLE YOU WORK WITH, THE
PEOPLE YOU CARE ABOUT.
THE PEOPLE YOU LOVE.
AINSLEY: PRESIDENT BIDEN’S NEW
PLAN TO FIGHT COVID-19 NOW
REQUIRING ALL EMPLOYERS WITH 100
OR MORE WORKERS TO FULLY
VACCINATE THEIR WORKFORCES OR
SHOW A NEGATIVE TEST AT LEAST
ONCE A WEEK.
THE SEVERITY ALSO IMPACTING
HOSPITALS, HOME HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES AND ALL THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH FEDERAL WORKERS AND EVEN
FEDERAL CONTRACTORS.
BUT OUR NEXT GUEST SAYS THESE
MANDATES ARE MISSING THE MARK.
FOX NEWS MEDICAL CONTRIBUTOR
DR. NICOLE SAPHIER JOINS US NOW.
GOOD MORNING, DR. SAPHIER.
>> GOOD MORNING, AINSLEY.
AINSLEY: THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
DON’T HAVE A CHOICE.
THEY HAVE TO GET VACCINATED.
FEDERAL CONTRACTORS HAVE TO GET
VACCINATED.
THEY DON’T HAVE THE OPTION TO
TEST EVERY WEEK.
I HEARD CLAUDIA COWAN A
CONGRESSWOMAN FROM NEW YORK SAY
SHE HAD TWO CONSTITUENCY CALL
HER AND SAY THEY WERE PREGNANT.
THEIR DOCTORS TOLD THEM NOT TO
GET THE VACCINE UNTIL AFTER THE
BABY WAS BORN AND THEY WERE
FIRED.
WHAT DO YOU SAY ABOUT THIS?
>> WELL, I CAN TELL YOU,
AINSLEY, THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY
RIGHT NOW WE ARE STARTING TO SEE
SHORTAGES IN STAFFING, WHETHER
IT’S NURSES, TECHNOLOGISTS, AND
NOW I SUSPECT YOU ARE GOING TO
SEE OTHER STAFFING SHORTAGES
COMING FROM THESE NEW MANDATES.
THESE ARE ALL MAN MADE
SHORTAGES.
THERE ARE A FEW THINGS, AINSLEY,
YESTERDAY THAT I HEARD PRESIDENT
BIDEN SAY THAT I LIKED.
HE DISCUSSED INCREASING
PRODUCTION OF THE MONOCLONAL
ANTIBODIES.
THAT’S GREAT.
THEY ARE PROVEN EFFECTIVE TO
KEEP PEOPLE OUT OF THE HOSPITAL.
HE DIDN’T GO FAR ENOUGH TO SAY
HE WAS GOING TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
OUTPATIENT CENTERS AND PRIMARY
CARE DOCTORS TO GIVE THOSE
MONOCLONAL ANTIBODIES.
IT DOESN’T HELP THAT MUCH.
HE SAID HE IS GOING TO INCREASE
PRODUCTION ANTIGEN TEST TO THE
DEFENSE PRODUCTION ACT.
THAT’S GREAT.
HE DIDN’T SAY RAPID TESTS ARE
GOING TO BE IN LIEU OF CHILDREN
HAVING TO BE KEPT HOME IN
QUARANTINE BECAUSE OF CLOSE
CONTACTS OR EVEN EMPLOYEES.
WE NEED TO MOVE THIS MARK
FORWARD TO ACTUALLY HELP PEOPLE.
WE HAD TO KEEP OUR CHILDREN IN
SCHOOL WITH THESE RAPID TESTS.
WE NEED TO KEEP PEOPLE AT WORK
BECAUSE WE HAVE SO MANY PEOPLE
UNNECESSARILY QUARANTINING.
AGAIN, HE DIDN’T GO FAR ENOUGH.
IF YOU THINK HIS OBVIOUS DISDAIN
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE NOT
GOTTEN VACCINATED HELPS PEOPLE
LIKE ME CONVINCE THE VACCINE
HESITANT TO GET VACCINATED.
YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY WRONG.
SO MOVING FORWARD, BY SAYING
THAT HE WANTS TO PROTECT THE
VACCINATED FROM THE UNVACCINATED
WITH THESE MANDATES HE IS JUST
FURTHER UNDERMINING THE
CONFIDENCE IN THE VACCINES.
THE MESSAGE SHOULD BE THESE
VACCINES ARE DOING A GREAT JOB
AT PROTECTING PEOPLE FROM SEVERE
ILLNESS AND DEATH.
AND HE SHOULD ENCOURAGE EVERYONE
TO TALK TO THEIR DOCTORS.
BUT, UNFORTUNATELY, HE CONTINUED
WITH HIS GROUP THINK ARE
REGARDING VACCINES WHICH IS
COMPLETELY WRONG.
THEY ARE FAR TOO BLACK AND
WHITE.
THEY ARE NOT PROVIDING MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS FOR SOME PEOPLE WHO
MAY HAVE SOME SORT OF MEDICAL
CONDITION WHERE THEIR PHYSICIAN
DOESN’T BELIEVE THEY SHOULD BE
VACCINATED OR MAYBE THEY HAVE
ALREADY RECOVERED FROM COVID-19
AND HAVE NATURAL IMMUNITY.
AND LIKELY DON’T NEED TWO DOSES.
THIS GROUP THINK IS COMPLETELY
WRONG AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO MISS
THE MARK BY NOT FOLLOWING THE
SCIENCE.
AINSLEY: THERE ARE REPORTS
CHANGES IN MONTHLY CYCLE.
REPORTS VACCINE?
>> THE NIH IS PUTTING FORTH
$1.5 MILLION TO VARIOUS
INSTITUTIONS ACROSS THE STUDY
BECAUSE THERE HAVE BEEN REPORTS
ABOUT THAT.
I DON’T WANT PEOPLE TO GET
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT BECAUSE YOU
HAVE TO KNOW WHEN IT COMES TO
MENSTRUAL CYCLES A LOT OF THINGS
CAN WILL ALTER THAT HEAVY
EXERCISING, STRESS, MEDICATIONS,
AND JUST DAILY LIFE CAN ALTER
YOUR MENSTRUAL CYCLE.
BECAUSE OF REPORTS OF IT, THEY
ARE GOING TO LOOK INTO IT.
IT’S POSSIBLE THE INFLAMMATION
FROM THE VACCINE MAY HAVE
CHANGED THE CYCLE ARE A MONTH OR
TWO.
THIS DOESN’T TRANSLATE INTO
LONG-TERM FERTILITY ISSUES.
AINSLEY: THERE IS A PROFESSOR
SUING OVER THE VACCINE MANDATE
BECAUSE HE SAYS HE HAS NATURAL
IMMUNITY.
IS THAT SOMETHING YOU SHOULD
CONSIDER IF YOU HAVE NATURAL
IMMUNITY DO YOU HAVE TO GET THE
VACCINE IF THERE IS A MANDATE?
>> I THINK IT IS HIGH TIME THE
CDC, OTHER ELITE INSTITUTIONS
AND BIDEN ADMINISTRATION START
ACKNOWLEDGING THE AMPLE DATA
THAT SHOWS THERE IS PROTECTION
FROM NATURAL IMMUNITY.
THE CDC’S WEBSITE ONLY DISCUSSES
ONE SMALL CASE CONTROL STUDY OUT
OF KENTUCKY THAT SHOWED THAT
THERE WAS A HIGHER RATE OF
REINFECTION FOLLOWING INFECTION
THAN VACCINATION.
BUT THAT GOES AGAINST ALL OF
THESE OTHER STUDIES THROUGHOUT
THE UNITED STATES AND THROUGHOUT
THE WORLD WHICH ARE MUCH LARGER
STUDIES THAT SHOW THERE IS GREAT
PROTECTION FROM NATURAL
IMMUNITY.
THERE IS ALSO VERY GOOD
PROTECTION EVEN BETTER FROM ONE
DOSE OF THE VACCINE FOLLOWING
INFECTION.
THEY DON’T NECESSARILY NEED THAT
SECOND DOSE.
WHY THEY CANNOT GET PAST THIS
BLACK AND WHITE EVERYONE NEEDS
THE TWO DOSES REALLY BOGGLES THE
MIND.
THE CDC ACKNOWLEDGES NATURAL
IMMUNITY WITH SO MANY OTHER
VIRAL INFECTIONS.
THEY ARE GETTING IN THEIR OWN
WAY RIGHT NOW WHEN IT COMES TO
ACKNOWLEDGING NATURAL IMMUNITY.
WE NEED TO FOCUS ON THE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE NOT VACCINATED WHO HAVE
NOT RECOVERED FROM COVID-19.
THOSE PEOPLE STILL REMAIN THE
MOST VULNERABLE.